i'm curious is there is there a story
angle or a pitch under that multiverse
umbrella that could convince you to
reprise wolverine what's up everybody
it's warren and welcome back to the
cosmic wonder where we talk all things
marvel and mcu and as marvel dives deep
into the multiverse a lot of things
suddenly become possible within the mcu
not only have we branched away from one
singular universe but now we have active
universes alternate universes being
created which can actually interact with
each other and of course we believe that
the prime example of this happening is
going to be in spider-man no way home
where we have all three spider-man and
different villains interacting with each
other in one universe and of course
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness now right now the rumors and
reports for multiverse of madness are
kind of going crazy because again
essentially everything is possible in
that movie a lot of characters could
return and one of those rumored and
hoped for characters is hugh jackman's
wolverine everyone's wondering if he
could return but recently he actually
addressed this in an interview with jake
hamilton he talked if he could return if
he's spoken to kevin feige about it and
he actually talks about ryan reynolds as
well so if you love marvel content be
sure to subscribe and also if you want
to hear a crazy cool thanos secret wars
theory you can head over to chaos
multiverse and i'll link that in the
description down below so let's dive
into this like i mentioned jake hamilton
recently interviewed hugh jackman and he
posted his interview on his youtube
channel jake's takes in this interview
they talked about hugh jackman's
upcoming movie but of course you have to
ask hugh jackman if he is ever going to
return as wolverine because that's just
something that everybody wants to know
and that's what was asked however jake
presented this in a very good way he
talked about it in terms of the
multiverse not hugh jackman returning in
the main mcu to play wolverine for
another few years but in a multiversal
form of a wolverine from a different
universe perhaps just making a cameo
this is how he phrased his question
is there is there a story angle or a
pitch under that multiverse umbrella
that could convince you to reprise
wolverine now real quick i actually
really like how he asked this question
because he asked to jackman if there was
anything to him that could get him to
return also he talked about how in
spider-man no way home they are going to
bring the other two spider-men back and
all three spider-man are going to fight
together side note don't get carried
away taking this as any type of
confirmation as jake is most likely just
repeating what everybody has been
reporting in regards to spider-man that
is but hugh jackman replies and says a
couple of interesting things here that
we should talk about and break down and
kind of read between the lines
well
the fact jake that i'm hearing about
this from you
and there's nothing in my inbox from
kevin feige means it's probably no
matter what idea i came up with
not on the table let's just be clear
there but okay so this first part is
kind of important but could also be him
trying not to spoil anything he says
that nothing is in his email inbox from
kevin feige about him reprising the role
of wolverine however this may be a
misdirect and the reason i say this is
because we actually have an official
confirmation that kevin feige has been
meeting with some of the old x-men
characters and talking to them about
reprising their roles very briefly as
cameos in upcoming marvel films patrick
stewart was one of those people he
himself came out and said that he met
with kevin feige and this was last year
probably right around the time that they
were getting the script ready for doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness he
straight up said that he met with kevin
feige at marvel studios and they talked
about plans for professor x this is
literally confirmed it's coming directly
from the mouth of patrick stewart
himself however he would go on to say
that he has laid his character to rest
logan was the end for him he said
goodbye to the character and didn't want
to bring it back however this is the
multiverse so it would be a different
variant of that character and that's the
really appealing thing here is they
don't have to undo everything that
happened in logan and in the other fox
franchise this could be a completely
different universe in which they reprise
their character but the pure fact that
kevin feige met with patrick stewart
means that there is no reason why he
wouldn't talk to hugh jackman as well
especially because he is the iconic
x-men from the movies he is wolverine
it's him patrick stewart and ian
mckellen wolverine professor x and
magneto so i wouldn't be surprised if he
actually did meet with kevin feige but
he's trying to be coy about it and not
really say anything about it to keep
rumors from flying around but he does go
on to say more in the interview
now i
i i realized
before we shot logan
i was like
we got the idea we knew what it was
going to be
ish right
and i thought this is it and that really
helped me it really helped knowing i was
going into my last season that it was my
last season that i made the most of it
and it's still
a character i hold close to my heart
but i know it's done tell tell that to
it whoever you want but please tell it
to ryan because he's like doesn't
believe anything some joke please
i'll tell i'll call him i'll call him so
hugh jackman says that he knows that the
character is done however i always say
that millions of dollars can change
people's minds because millions of
dollars really can change people's minds
especially like i said if a cameo
doesn't actually undo that work that you
did before that story that you did
before you see what hugh jackman is
specifically talking about is he doesn't
want to come back as wolverine and undo
what he did before because he was
perfectly fine with the way it ended
with the story of logan however this
doesn't mean that he can't simply make a
cameo much like he did with his famous
cameo in x-men first class
excuse me i'm eric mantra xavier got
i think hugh jackman would be open for a
cameo to just play himself not play
wolverine not whip out the claws but
maybe a funny little cameo where he just
pops up for a few seconds especially if
you consider the fact that it does look
like ryan reynolds is bugging him a lot
about reprising the role of wolverine
because much like all of us ryan
reynolds does not believe that hugh
jackman is done as wolverine hugh
jackman makes this pretty clear when he
says please tell ryan because he does
not believe me we all know that ryan
reynolds is really trying to get hugh
jackman to make an appearance in one of
his deadpool films they had a lot of
references to hugh jackman in the very
first one and in the second one in the
post-credits scene they used old footage
of hugh jackman and i definitely think
that at one point in time hugh jackman
is going to be in either a deadpool film
or an mcu film even if it's just a joke
which you know i almost preferred that
it would be in like a deadpool film i
think eventually he will actually come
back just for a quick cameo nothing huge
i don't think he's going to reprise his
role in wolverine in any way whatsoever
i think that when he says that he's done
that's what he's referring to he is done
playing wolverine a main mc wolverine
isn't going to be played by hugh jackman
we're going to get a new young fresh
actor to play a new wolverine because
we're going to need somebody who can
commit to essentially 10 years of
playing that character and that's not
hugh jackman that's why hugh jackman
keeps saying that he's done because he's
not going to commit to another 10 years
heck he probably doesn't even want to
commit to six months the training that
he went through every day to be in
wolverine shape was absolutely
ridiculous so when i say that i do think
he's going to make an appearance don't
think i mean that he's going to reprise
the role as wolverine i just think that
we are going to be getting a cameo from
him in some way shape or form down the
road in the mcu whether that's in
deadpool or we do truly get him making a
cameo in multiverse of madness i think
it's gonna happen but it does pretty
much look like he's done with wolverine
logan was his goodbye like he said
before in the past him bringing out the
claws again isn't gonna happen but he
could simply pop up and say hi and i
think this would still be amazingly cool
i think every fan in the world of
wolverine would absolutely freak out
because that would technically make him
part of the mcu but what do you think
about this would you like to see him
just make a cameo even if it's just as
himself or do you think that he is
completely done and will never see him
pop up again in deadpool or in the mcu
in any way let me know your thoughts in
the comments down below don't forget to
like this video and for live updates you
can always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching woof